after all the bag there is still a
little more to go but it's not as hard
conception okay um that's sexy on the
denominator it's a reciprocal identity
right so really it's actually a cos
theta on the top right so this looks
like this
ok now just going to pause for a second
some of you have seen this question
before how many of you attempted it got
this far already yeah were you able to
erase your past if there's someone give
me a suggestion because this is
certainly not a form i reckon comes
right like oh yes I've been resistant
though I didn't what do I do with it see
I'm it's f dash of x 1 f of X ok of
course what it's ok ok now let's just
work because it's something to let me
get right post were close what does this
look like it certainly looks a lot like
f dashiell now it looks a lot like it's
like [ __ ] but it's not quite what what
what would I need to have f dash on you
very much someone what is just not use
it was just a single sine theta I'd be
there right as it is as a stands right
now like what is the derivative of the
denominator what is it
I'm going to do I'm going to the inside
there will be outside okay actually I'm
going to the inside first the inside
function is actually sine theta so if
it's derivative is closed and the
outside is signed something square right
so the power comes down the front and
then the power reduces by one yeah so
this is what I would need to have on my
numerator in order for this to fit
nicely into f dashiell death so
unfortunately it does not what else
could I do yeah goes general ok I am
going to use reverse chain rule here
okay it's just not quite as neat have a
look at this now this you don't expect
to have to do this cuz you like I
already did a substitution which is a
way of doing remotes change by like
there it is right there okay like really
answer yes ok so what substitution could
work here that could let me use your bus
change yes wait ye are change the bottom
two one and what might help it on and it
just like master so you're suggesting I
use the Pythagorean identity identity
are so i end up with something like this
why don't like something like this what
are you suggesting i do with this hi you
master possibly like you asked one
advice
I'm sorry no seriously I do that yeah
device get this thing okay sorry let's
just pause for a second what's let's
just pause to see what Junsu is doing ok
and then we'll see where it goes ok what
chance is trying to do here is he sees
oh ok I can like we always look for ways
that we can you know rearrangements yeah
you know there's a cos theta on the top
part really do much with that but we
know if you've got squared three
functions you can always do some kind of
switching so he does his Swedish like so
so there's just the strength switch yeah
and then he says well I can't do
anything with that still at the moment
because the top of the bottom the
factorization to confuse I can do with
here but if I do this will this be
helpful
now I'm just going to take it a little
bit further and then I'm going to rock
your paws on it okay here's where I
think Jin she was trying to go boiling
where this goes is to say okay I am
carless theater- actually I suppose we
could leave is applause that's fine I'm
over now this guy down here I can
factorize its difference of squares do
you agree with that yeah that's that's
this part excuse me yeah and then you've
got this see that now the reason why we
could try and do something ok cancel
cancel your one left on the top there
now I I put to you is that any better
than what I started with uncle and
unfortunately in this particular case it
ended up being pretty much an
unmitigated disaster ok if this was all
polynomials you sometimes do pull this
trick and we'll have a look at that
later if it was all x is x squared
excuse whatever you have a little more
luck with this method but in this case
sorry buddy ok so here's what I'm going
to suggest is that because we see this
as a fraction we see it as a fraction it
looks as though you'd lean toward a
shore there right but in fact has
rejoicing that that ended up in use so
I'm gonna rewrite it one more time now
hopefully you see it a little cleaner is
already suggested we should use reverse
chain rule somehow
so I'm going to do it
okay now what have I done okay what
about them all i've done is i've
rewritten like we know that that
denominator there is sine theta all
square okay it's on the denominator
there's no reason why I can't write it
with a negative index now why would we
do that the answer is well what will be
searching for 44 we're searching for a
relationship between this side like
we're like that's clearly an F dash and
this is f right it's just not that's not
there right side squared is not have
that guy taking another day or two that
is ok so i couldn't do this on my own
but my head will hurt so what I'm going
to do is just like I did here i'm going
to introduce a new substitution I use X
I just stay down okay I'm going to go
into you again I haven't used
so I'm going to let you yeah I'm okay
what I gonna do with this lady okay
52
and then you like okay so what I'm
trying to do here you remember before I
landed here and then I was like that
dream it is not the way I wanted I
wanted the DX of the bottom so that it
would cancel with this what you did is
this in the configuration that I want it
is right not only is it the
configuration at one but in fact this
guy is already in my integral right so
I'm not going to touch that I'm not
gonna do any dividing or rearranging I'm
just going to say oh look okay I can
come ready to do my substitution I'm
gonna say this is 1 over 9 integral off
thats do you on d theta
and as we had to put them at the front
there the line operator is operating on
huge that these days does what's this
guy right this is I used to the power of
video to agree and then there's that DK
what you're still hanging off on the end
here which cancels now that's weird but
it's ok i just need to tidy very tidy up
let's tidy up
so I've got my whatever hang out the
front this is let's write up in a proper
order you're the negative 2t you saw use
the minus one over you
whoa just
I increase the power by one and then I /
money power like so so this is minus 10
nothing yeah which is now this is
hilarious right but this is like you
know how inception right thank your dad
levels and then they have to climb back
out of the levels right exactly what is
happening here i'm down to levels don't
go down because then the end up an uber
right um I'm gonna climb out of this
so that's minus one over nine sign here
it's my case is trying but then but then
wait wait wait I wanted tans I want to
dance right that's what I can sense you
directly for X but that's okay way back
here I introduced a restriction that
means i can use a triangle right I've
got a side leader miss Deena so what's
this side up here yep yeah it's a high
pocket last night so therefore sign
theater in this case is opposite on high
pronounced sir i minus 1 over i'm not
going to do it just yet just because i'm
too paranoid right I'm gonna do I don't
want to grow up uh-huh so that's their
use the big things but there's sine
theta so now I'm going to do the Flip
which looks to me like minus the square
root of nine plus X with on
and x
okay now can we pause for a second this
is actually something that it will be
very very cruel to find an extension one
exam you can all of this stuff that I
just demonstrated it took us a long time
because i was explaining as i went and
we rent out some rabbit holes and so on
thanks a lot about it okay but we got
there and all I used was with extension
one stuffed okay I'm being that you got
given this it's not an extension to Duke
last question but almost certainly
almost certainly this is going to get
presented to you in parts I would expect
this question to provoke represented in
two parts each of which would be worth
two marks okay so four marks because
there's so many things here whereas most
intimate just by themselves our three
where's this [ __ ] fine um so I'm
probably expect the second part would
have something to do with the second
substitution all right you can see this
is kinda it's cool because it's too
close to the whole questions bold into
one like this so you see what we did
this this is a whole question and then
this guy over here is our whole question
right so that's why it
I will point out there's one more thing
I should say when I get stuck here
see that man there of that line um this
is actually if I think about it the
course on signs it's called sign there
it is also a one side yeah cause I sign
is
and one other side is now there is
actually a little-known identity
measurements that and this again this is
another way that the paper could kind of
sort of give you a bit of a knowledge um
if you differentiate I think it's cuz I
was it negative ah yeah you're gonna get
negative confit our code sec theta right
also this could turn into one of those
differentiate hits in two great
questions you're different here's the
way would hope you would differentiate
Jose feel right and then you would get
this is an answer right and then if you
therefore want to integrate the thing on
the right hand side you would say okay
so the integral of this thing
the integral of this thing
ya see one aren't just integrated
everything with respect to feet are okay
stay with me because it actually gets
kind of cool up there's something
interesting to the lunacy i actually
won't but my decide to be up because
there is right out of having an image
there so i better be over there this is
actually the thing i wanted value rings
that's thumbs up look at this guy what
happens here now you've got d thing is
canceling just like we've been doing all
the way through so you look at this
weird thing what on earth is this now
here's the name right here's the thing
what is that if i say to you hey what's
the integral of DX your life hey what's
up with that okay there's really a one
hiding there is there not really a one
you doing one of courses because the
idea is how is this changing with
respect to X Man series is changing one
at a time because that's what y equals x
looks like okay now what this is asking
is how is it changing with respect to
cosec theta how is one I'll changing
with respect to cosec together the
answer is it's per second
Plus Costume right in fact the integral
of anything like you could go the
integral of high well isin number okay
you can do the rule of Applejack
my new actor that's just a fundamental
part of like what does it mean interior
with your tricks or something if you can
Terry one you just get back this
something just like kill me right that
is like oh yeah don't do news chann is
you're a dummy variable I don't think
that Sun helpful or nice to jail sir